Hơn bà mấy đổi tim kiếm quy tập 2 có nổi xí đã được thành lập phóng tăng cường được lợp.
Các đơn vì đây mạnh thu thập, xác mình thông tin từ cơ sở lông thời ứng dụng ra đa xuyên đất,
công nghệ số vá phần mềm của liy nhằm nâng cao hiểu của tìm kiếm.
Đến này, hình bà miệng bà nghìn mẫu sinh phẩm tại cáo phần mỗi xí đã được lấy,
trong đó trên năm gìn mẫu đủ điều kiệm phần tiết RDNFu vụ công tác xa định dành tính.
Công vui đó hơn tảng nghìn năm 2018 đã đã được giả phá mong mình,
tạo điều kiệm thật lợp ở trong hạt động tiêm kiếm quy tập.
Thôi đánh giả của được lượng trứng năng, công tác tiêm kiếm với các nhiều khó khăn gió địa hình
đi ở vật thay đổi sau trên tranh, phô sơ và sơ đồ mộ chưa để đủ.
Nhật khu vực còn tôn liệu bó mình trong khi nhìn trứng ngại gạng ít,
đến cạnh đó 2 có được ăn tảng từ nhiều nằm trước khiến việc giảm định AdNF gặp không ít trưởng ngại.
Chính dịch năm 2018 được trên khá trên phẩm vi cả nước.
Nhằm nệ mạnh công tác tiêm kiếm, quy tập và xác định dành thay có lý xí,
trên người đã hí xinh về đập lập từ gió của tổ quốc.